what do we know about Britain's role in
slavery mostly our focus is on claiming
the credit for ending it with heroic
stories about William Wilberforce
and the abolitionists we remain
painfully unaware of Britain's
transatlantic slave trade now
London Mayor Sadiq Khan has bought
proposals to build a British slavery
Museum in London to help challenge
racism at least 12 million African
people were forced into slavery and
Britain traded millions of these stolen
lives forcing them onto slave ships
across the Atlantic in unimaginable
conditions Britain grew wealthy because
of its transatlantic slave trade which
powered the Industrial Revolution and
helped build the banking industry as
well as the nation's ports canals roads
and cities we shouldn't shy away from an
honest conversation about this and a new
slavery Museum in the capital could be a
cornerstone of that discussion of course
it won't make racism disappear but it
can help us understand where racism
comes from it can help us understand
Britain's history as a slave trading
nation and it can help us understand the
responsibilities Britain has for global
inequalities that are still playing out
today a museum in the sense that it will
be telling a very powerful story but I
mean don't kid yourself it's gonna help
tackle or solve racism in any way shape
or form racism won't suddenly milk or
melt away because the powerful light of
truth has been shown upon it it's naive
to think it will and the fact is the
very people who need to learn about
about racism and about where it came
from or not the kind of people that will
go to a slave museum in London or in
Liverpool because let me finish because
they don't care they're not empathetic
they're not sympathetic but let me make
a point that I'll shut up about it
and you know I think we've got to stop
two hundred three hundred years and
we've got to stop beating ourselves up
about the slave trade
we were not uniquely oppressive our
history was not exceptional we were
doing what you have
describe you were we were doing what you
just described at a time when most
societies were doing it when it was
normal for the strong to enslave the
weak that has changed we can't change
that what we can't we can't change the
past but we can change the future and I
think this country has taken massive
strides to change what happened in the
past but we can't we can't blame people
to do that moment when we so beat
ourselves up about the slave trade for
example can you name a single person who
is enslaved by the British can i yeah
what do you mean there were how can I
will be twenty million Africans enslaved
Britain was contrary to what you said
actually a pioneer when I in developing
and industrializing the slave trade it
was a major slave trading nation and
actually many combinations weren't doing
it we were just away right so if we've
had this whole period where we beat
ourselves up and it's time to move on
when was that and who can you name which
of these millions of Africans that we
enslaved who were branded with our royal
seal because the royal family owned the
company that enslaved them which of them
could you name tell me anything about
any of that I put in a very emotional
argument forward but the people who will
go to the slave you museum and learn
about slavery all the people who will
already have a very good idea about what
happened I've just asked you a question
do I know anyone who was enslaved the
answer to that question is not would you
go to a museum of course I then I think
there would be a benefit in having me
say maybe you would learn I would want
one of the reasons I would welcome a
museum is that I also think that I have
much to learn about this I went to the
museum of slavery in Liverpool I found
that an incredibly informative
experience in the sense that we don't
really know the extent to which it has
powered this country let me finish
Carole that the trade in slavery and
slave produced goods cotton
tobacco created the wealth in this
country it powered the Industrial
Average let me finish Carol it powered
the Industrial Revolution it created it
produced entire new industries cotton
manufacturing I'm not saying it's about
understanding Britain's responsibility I
think British slavery Museum in London
doesn't necessarily imply that our role
in history was unique so I think that's
a bit of a straw man in that nobody
claimed that it means that we were
uniquely to blame in history I think
actually does serve an educational role
the point you mentioned about racists
wouldn't attend anyway I think there is
a point you're missing here which is
children would go to this museum and
they'd be there'll be school trips as
there are to all museums and of course
children can learn as they're growing
about the history and that stops on a
preventive sign it can stop somebody
growing to become kids what is it Khan
who's the director of the rani me trust
my wife slavering zoom in London will be
a good idea it's important that we
reflect and commemorate on those times
in the past when we and other nations
failed to live up those values because
we learn more morally and politically
from those times when we fail to live up
to those values it's not inevitable that
we will always support democracy
equality and freedom for everyone I
think that fantastic what a good idea
but can I just be assured Rachael they
didn't would also because it will show
all the dark side absolutely but it will
also celebrate the fact that Britain was
involved in bringing it to an end the
museum would show that as well because
so the museum
will the museum show that sure welcome
William world before so let's be honest
let's also mention all the black people
who were part of ending slavery we
missed out the people who resisted and
revolted for hundreds of years that led
to the eventual abaca but also we
discussed this about slavery on this
show I did erroneously say that we
needed Britain needed a slavery of
course there is one corrected by the
museum of slavery in Liverpool
themselves online so I do need to say
thank you for that we should ought to be
fair it wasn't William Wilberforce that
actually started the end of it was
actually making a documentary series
that looks at the role of Africans in
slavery that looks at the role of black
people in resistances Rach was saying
hundreds of rebellions on the high seas
mutinies rebellions on plantations
things that we as Britain were
absolutely against we use our
parliamentary democracy to try and stop
black people claiming their lives I want
the whole story to be known because it
is complex and it's also not tangential
to our history it is our history it is
absolutely essential to understanding
our economy our society our politics all
of it I would just say Carol you know
you said I called you racist we actually
didn't but I would just like to say I
would like to say define racist because
to me it's not this thing that terrible
bad thugs do racism is a system that has
structurally and over centuries
discriminated against people of color
denied them resources taken away their
inheritance in their culture and if
you're not actively fighting that then
you're part of it and you're complicit
in it and that's something that people
also don't understand and another
excellent idea as to why we should have
a museum and I actually don't think that
this slavery museum well I think it is a
great idea it's not enough I want a
museum of empire of all of the ways in
which Britain engaged with the world and
in many ways
people's self-determination I want the
whole story not just the bits gave you
the DVD just ask me why I thought you
suggested that I was racist you actually
asked me if I would visit a slavery
museum I didn't believe for one second
that I would it was because you were
saying I'm not interesting they would
visit so that's why I said I was saying
racism would not refuse it a slave you
talked about the people who visit and
you said they that's why I was asking
you well sure I've said they and I